[Applause]
I'm gonna start off today's video by
asking you a question
and please don't google it oh well would
you just read the title of this episode
but it doesn't really matter anyway
we're betting that you didn't know that
angola was the world's most expensive
country and if you did well well done to
you well when it comes to expensive
places to live most people think of New
York or Hong Kong or Zurich well that's
not even close to right the world's most
expensive city is Luann's er the capital
city of Angola and yep that's an African
country if you want to rent an apartment
in Luanda you can end up paying over
five thousand dollars a month
how about the cost of a Big Mac menu at
Mackie DS well that's nineteen American
dollars and if you want sever the
internet connection I mean well you'd
better hope you've got a healthy bank
balance because that's gonna cost you
around three hundred dollars a month and
they were not kidding all right so now
you might be wondering what the hell's
going on in Angola this is some sort of
extremely wealthy country that no one
knows about
[Music]
well no the Republic of Angola is one of
the world's biggest oil exporters
surpassing other oil-rich countries like
Qatar nevertheless half of its
population has no access to clean water
two out of every three children suffer
from malnutrition and one out of every
six dies before reaching five years of
age right on the other end of the
spectrum Angola is home to one of the
wealthiest women on the planet and that
would be Isabel dos Santos who by the
way is the daughter of former president
Josiah duardo dos Santos at this point
you might be figuring out what's going
on here ah yes
Angola is one of the most corrupt
countries on the planet indeed it was
home to one of the biggest financial
Fiasco's in recent years with several
companies losing billions of dollars in
this country well perhaps this is no
surprise to you I mean at the end of the
day Angola is still a third world
country nevertheless there is a question
that must be asked here how did they get
here how could a country possibly have
such a bizarre economy and more
importantly how is it possible that the
ruling party manages to keep control of
this country well today are you going to
answer those questions but first we do
need to have a look at the history
[Music]
diamonds blood and diplomacy first thing
we need to understand when we talk about
Africa is that most of the African
countries were colonies in past
centuries
european powerhouses like belgium france
and portugal invaded most of the
continent imposing rules and treating
the natives like animals and going up it
was no exception until 1975 portugal
made a fortune with its diamond mines in
the country nevertheless in that same
the portuguese government pushed by the
UN and its own people recognized and
gona's self-determination and then the
question was what happens after a
country stops being a colony who takes
care of the governmental affairs after
the European colonizers need
[Applause]
well instead of answering this question
by calling for elections the many
Angolan tribes created different fronts
and started a civil war well that was a
conflict that then went on to last 25
years and there are still parts of the
country today where you can't go because
they're just covered in landmines in
case you don't know what a landmine is
it is a bomb that you bury underground
then when someone steps on it explodes
and well now you might be wondering how
is it possible that such a poor country
could afford all of those weapons and it
was a big long civil war
[Music]
well the answer that one lies in the
diamonds that we previously mentioned
all sides of the conflict sold diamonds
and in exchange got arms but who
provided these arms
well after 1976 when true Civil War
kicked off there were two sides on the
one hand there was the unit a group who
dominated the south of the country unit
er was supported by South Africa China
and to a lesser extent to the United
States
those were the days of the Cold War and
every war in any part of the globe was
seen as a good opportunity to weaken
Soviet influence thus it was known that
Angola had oil reserves this also
explains why the Soviet Union wanted to
take part in the conflict - they were
supporters of the Angolan people's
liberation movements or as they called
it the MPLA but most of the war this
leader of the MPLA was josie Eduardo dos
Santos now dos Santos did have the
support of the Soviet Union but
interestingly the country that offered
the most support was actually Cuba and
we were following our internationalist
duty Fidel Castro he didn't stop at
selling weapons did or Santos he sent
over 30,000 troops to the country but
not only that during the nineteen
eighties the area that was under the
MPLA control received a lot of doctors
and engineers from Havana
this explains partly why da Santos won
the conflict in fact despite the war
still being ongoing during the 1990s
this man had taken control of most of
the country however that Cuban helped
well it wasn't as useful as you might
think
for example the agriculture experts in
from Cuba tried to grow sugar cane on
Angolan soil but apparently those seeds
were not good for the kind of soil that
you find in Angola
[Music]
and this is why within just a few years
most of the farming lands in the country
became totally infertile
this meant stole vation fur angolans and
an anger towards the cuban help alright
so as if this really wasn't enough after
the collapse of the Soviet Union Eduardo
dos Santos realized that it's a good
idea to befriend the capitalist
countries
[Music]
at the end of the day these were the
countries which would buy their oil on
the other hands America was not helping
unit or anymore
so what did this country need to do to
become an ally of these so-called free
wells well there was only one thing to
do when that was removed the word
Marxist from their vocabulary and swap
it out for free market democracy and yes
I do say that with a touch of sarcasm
because Angolan capitalism bailed it's
certainly one of a kind
c'mon nursing the angolan way the year
2002 is a turning point in Angola in
history Eduardo dos Santos signed the
peace agreements with his adversaries
since then unit er has become a
political party with a right to run for
elections and for the first time in
history Angolans could enjoy democracy
but not only that in the very same year
another meaningful thing vp makes first
ultra-deepwater oil discovery off the
coast of Angola suddenly Angola became
an oil juggernaut selling tons of
dinosaur juice to China in the United
States in just five years and golem
multiplied its wealth and goal as
capital is being rebuilt the varied
architecture from the 50s and 60s is
giving way to new office towers that are
being built between the national
corporate sector and the in Golin
government companies like ExxonMobil in
the US or BP in the UK invested heavily
in Angola and of course and they sent
engineers and workers to live in the
capital of new Anza and of course these
people wanted good quality houses cool
bars and these same kinds of goods that
they could buy that kind but all of
those things they're hard to find in a
country their years before was having a
big old civil war in other words the
supply was small and yet the demand
wouldn't stop growing as a result the
prices of Western goods went absolutely
sky-high built for 500,000 people the
Angolan capital is now accommodating an
estimated five million even civil
servants with comfortable salaries have
trouble making ends meet
buzz wait just a minute because there's
more imagine we have a construction
company in China and we want to build a
housing Block in new anza well the first
thing we want to do is register a
company in Angola right well that
process can take over six months during
that time that's perfectly normal that
the government finds lots of problems
they asked me for this paver van
registry and that other report that you
probably don't have like the sort of
report that a nice stack of cash and
they do a sweaty palm under a table
could probably fix
[Music]
now according to several reports made by
organizations like transparency
international almost every company who
does business in angola has had to do
some sort of bribery of a government
official
but wait just a minute because this is
still not the end of it those oil
companies like exxon mobil or british
petroleum that were willing to do
business in angola as they were had to
establish partnerships with the
government or show an angle the Angola
state company
and now have a guess who is the head of
that company well yes that's our friend
we mentioned earlier Isabel dos Santos
the daughter of the former president of
the country
this explains why Isabel dos Santos
became the wealthiest women in Africa in
so little time
every major Angolan investment held by
dos Santos stems either from taking a
chunk of a company that wants to do
business in the country or from a stroke
of the president's pen that cut her into
the action for all of this time the
government of dos Santos the father
restricted access to the country for
international journalists in fact most
of the corruption scandals we know about
have been discovered by the governments
of the US and the UK of course with a
political climate like this no Angolan
wanted to start company at the end of
the day the reality was that you needed
to be a millionaire in order to pay
those various bribes and even if we
would put the cost of bribery aside just
with the basic bureaucracy you'll need a
thousand US dollars to start a normal
bar in Rwanda in the country as poor as
Angola a thousand dollars is an absolute
fortune but not only that these
international companies were not willing
to invest in the country more than the
absolute minimum required to extract the
oil so now you might wonder what were
the consequences of all this well the
outcome is that dinosaur juice is the
only Angolan export
in fact in the last decade the only new
Angolan businesses were crude oil
extraction plants and houses for its
workers by the year 2014
oil represented 97% of Angolan exports
[Music]
now at this point if you're a regular
visual politic view you might be
thinking this sounds pretty familiar to
me and that's probably because you've
seen our videos on Venezuela a country
with a similar economic system just like
what happens in Nicolas maduro's country
when the oil market price went down
Angola went right along with it so now
let's go back to the example of the
Chinese Construction Companies many
companies from China invested millions
building entire neighborhoods they expat
professionals coming to the country but
now there's no more oil industry then
therefore there's no more workers
four-lane highways without cars schools
with no pupils in under five years a
Chinese company built Columba using
Angola's oil credit lines with China but
part of Colombo feel like a ghost town
in summary there is only one winner in
that story and that person is Jose
Eduardo dos Santos and his daughter
Isabel who has already invested these
enormous profits overseas most of the
big Portuguese firms from GA LP to
Unitel are now under the control of this
family if Portugal was a colonizer in
the past well they've now become Angola
some money launderer and golden elites
have sent an estimated 190 billion
dollars out of the country and while the
entire country is having a crisis isabel
dos santos who identifies herself as on
webinar on a twitter account goes out
with celebrities like Kim Kardashian all
of this is being said you might have
guessed that the Dos Santos family is
not that popular you know
Gola right
[Music]
right not really in fact their political
party VN PLA keeps stealing the show
election after election getting over 70%
of the votes this past August 2017
Angola held an election and despite the
fact that Josie Eduardo dos Santos was
not accounted as anymore
his party won again and so now you might
be wondering well why does this happen
well I'm afraid that we're probably
never going to know
Ebola rejects EU election observers and
now the question really becomes is it
going to be possible find gonna to get
rid of this corrupt ruling class can
they follow the trend of those African
lions like garner or Rwanda well let us
know what you think in the comments
below and by the way I'd like to
recommend another political channel
which has great information about
geopolitics if you like us you'll like
them do check out the Caspian report you
can find a link in the description and
also don't forget to check out the
ricans of the media podcast they provide
the vocals in this episode that are not
mine and don't forget to subscribe to
this channel we put up brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so do
subscribe to get those and there's
always next video and if you want to
learn more about politics and here even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]